Росія видобуває стільки ж нафти скільки
і до війни в Україні і продає в ЄС
більше зрідженого газу ніж будь-коли
раніше Як таке може бути адже Євросоюз і
країни Великої сімки домовилися про
санкції проти російського експорту нафти
і газу ще влітку 2022
року санкції стали реакцією на
повномасштабне вторгнення Росії в
Україну але поки що вони має же не дали
ефекту навіть
навпаки у 2018 році Росія експортувала
близько 8 мльнів барелів нафти на день
протягом останніх пти років цей обсяг
залишався практично
незмінним один із санкційних заходів
танкерам які перевозять російську нафту
заборонили заходити в порти ЄС і країн
Великої сімки крім того суттєво
обмежується постачання нафти до Європи
наземними трубопроводами але реальність
інша десятки нафтових танкерів у тому
числі з країн Великої сімки чекають на
заповнення нафтою біля російських портів
таких як Новоросійськ і Мурманськ вони
доставляють нафту через Середземне море
або як цей російський танкер через
Берингове море переважно в Азію санкції
спочатку призвели до здешевлення
Російської нафти тож нафтопереробні
заводи в Азії скористалися можливістю і
розширили своє виробництво Наприклад
таких видів палива як бензин і
дизель саме тому Індія та Китай купують
більше російської сирої нафти через
низькі ціни вони можуть перепродавати
нафтопродукти на світовому ринку за
вищими
цінами однією з причин чому Індія та
Китай збільшили споживання російської
сирої нафти є знижені ціни у багатьох
випадках ці купують дешеву сиру нафту та
продають нафтопродукти на світовому
ринку з
надбавкою ще один санкційний захід
обмеження ціни на російську нафту на
рівні 60 доларів за барель що приблизно
на 20 доларів нижче за ринкову ціну
країни Великої сімки та ЄС ухвалили таке
рішення наприкінці 22го року але і це не
працює Як таке
можливо це пов'язано з механізмом
обмеження цін який дозволяє західним
компаніям суднола т і рахом продовжувати
сприяти торгівлі російською нафтою у
світі одна з причин у торгівлі нафтою є
лазівки а західні компанії недостатньо
контролюються чи можна цьому якось
протидіяти а переконатися що обмеження
ціни працює торгівля повинна
контролюватися і всі компанії повинні
дотримуватися правил і б як тільки це
спрацює наступним кроком буде ще більше
знизити максимальну
ціну наступна проблема процвітаюча
торгівля зрідженим газом у Росії санкції
проти російського газу який надходить до
Європи по трубопроводах працюють але до
європейських портів потрапляють дедалі
більші обсяги російського зрідженого
газу у 2021 році було поставлено 16 млрд
кубометрів зпг у перший рік війни у
22-му році 22 а в 23му році вже було
поставлено 13 млрд кубометрів і до кінця
року буде понад 22 млрд
кубометрів цього року ЄС закупив у
Кремля зарідженого газу на 5,3 млрда
Євро слід знати що торгівля російським
зпг в Європі не обмежується
ЄС не хоче вводити санкції щодо
російського зріддженого газу до 27го
року А тим часом санкції було
запроваджено не лише проти російських
нафти і газу але й проти цілих
російських галузей зокрема авіації під
забороною опини с як купівля нових
літаків так і запчастин до них Але й тут
виявилося чимало лазівок без нових
запчастин без сертифікованого технічного
обслуговування та без міжнародних
перевезень авіалайнери у Росії
продовжують літати трохи менше половини
з них були у лізингу і належать
іноземним компаніям але ці літаки Росія
присвоїла російські авіагалузі
пророкували серйозну кризу але цього так
і не
сталосям
авіакомпанія Победа експлуатує здається
41 літак boн 737 800 зрозуміло що їм уже
потрібно було би щось розібрати замінити
запчастини Але якщо ми подивимося за
реєстрами то всі літаки Победи успшно
літають причому літають Майже
щодня журналісти розслідувачі видання
важливі історії з'ясували російські
компанії продовжують закуповувати
запчастини та агрегати для літаків
тільки роблять це це тепер не через
офіційних постачальників а через
посередників які не розповідають куди в
підсумку підуть ці
запчастини Вони купують ці запчастини
буцімто для себе в основному це так
звані дружні країни Арабські Емірати
Туреччина Китай країни СНД і вони
вводять в оману західні компанії кажуть
що ці деталі призначаються не для Росії
швидше за все підробляють документи адже
постачальники зазвичай намагаються пере
дуть хні зачасти постачальники думають
що вони йдуть куди завгодно але не в
Росію а вони Зрештою опиняються в
росі у таких сірих схемах часто беруть
участь одразу кілька компаній
посередників з'ясувати хто кінцевий
покупець почасти неможливо оскільки
Далеко не всі країни діляться митними
даними до таких країн наприклад належать
Об'єднані Арабські
Емірати ком яки в змозі відстежити
ланцюги поставок і це досить нова і
складна конструкція з точки зору
контролю з боку регуляторів І тому ми
бачимо що через це діряве сито через
різні канали та різні країни до Росії
надходять товари подвійного призначення
включаючи агрегати для авіаційної галузі
аеронавігаційне обладнання та якісь інші
елементи електроніка наприклад
найбільший покупець авіазапчастин
російська компанія Аерофлот загалом за
такими схемами лі нарахували закупівель
на 18 млрдів
рублів тут зазначую йдеться лише про
запчастини саме до боїнгів Та ербасів бо
ці компанії одразу після початку війни
оголосили свою позицію є ще велика
кількість літаків і запчастин від різних
інших постачальників і вони В цю суму не
входять тобто насправді ми говоримо про
ще більшу суму деякими компаніями
посередниками володіють російські
громадяни іншими іноземці причому
частина з них на ринку
нещодавно зараз час можна сказати
Ельдорадо для таких тюньових торговців
посередників тюньових брокерів які
заробляють якщо не десятки мільйонів То
точно мільйони доларів на посередницьких
схемах ми бачимо наскільки вільно
почуваються такі посередники в цих
різних юрисдикціях із тими обсягами
коштів якими вони оперують припускаю що
значну частину цих коштів російська
держава просто готова переплачувати вдві
в просто тому що немає жодної
альтернативи для російського
військово-промислового комплексу
найбільші концерни boін та Airbus
намагаються контролювати продаж але
відстежити всі ланцюги поставок як
показує практика не в змозі не вдається
це поки що й контролюючим органам за
порушення санкцій зазвичай загрожує
кримінальна відповідальність але вона
діє тільки на території Європи та США
чим користуються сірі бізнесмени з інших
краї